et pour mieux comprendre les rouages de
ce jury populaire avec moi un plateau
notre gaz et river bâtonnier de l'ordre
des avocats du barreau de tours bonsoir
bonsoir
alors on l'a vu dans ce reportage c'est
parfois compliqué d'autres jurés
d'assises et vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est nécessaire quel est le
rôle de ce jury populaire dans
l'établissement de leur justice en cour
d'assises
le jury populaire il est là aussi pour
représenter la société
on a des crimes qui sont jugés en cour
d'assises et donc des choses qui sont
graff avec un roster humain avec un
facteur humain qui est indéniable et
c'est la société dans ces crimes graves
qui attaque de en dehors des victimes
évidemment directement
donc on a équilibré avec des
professionnels et des jurés populaires
qui on le sait prennent particulièrement
à coeur leur tâche est de plus en plus
donc le golf est d'accord d'assises dit
que c'est véritablement un vrai juge
avec les questions qu'il faut se poser
il se l'est posée ils sont très
attentifs
alors pour être juré il faut avoir plus
de 23 ans savoir lire et écrire français
jouèrent de tous les droits politiques
civils et familiaux et ne relève
d'aucune incapacité défini légalement
est ce que toutes les professions sont
compatibles à d'autres ce stade du ray
moi je crois que oui je n'ai pas vérifié
ce poids là mais par exemple les avocats
peuvent l'être et je veux pas pourquoi
un citoyen très exclus de ce que vous
dites simplement il ya juste quand on a
plus de 70 ans on peut demander à être
retiré de la liste des dégelées nomme
que non il ya un panel qui normale qui
est ce une société française des listes
de jurés potentiels sont établis donc
par département avec des tirages au sort
comme il y en aura un demain matin à
tours
si on est tirés au sort est ce que c'est
une obligation de se présenter une fois
qu'on est jurée d'assises il faut se
présenter parce que si on a pas on n'est
pas exempté par la cour d'assises on
encore hymne à prendre en main une
amende et le tribunal la cour d'assises
en proposant
un dessin est médicalement alors on peut
se faire exempter médicalement ce que ça
exemple par exemple pour la condition
d'art plus de 70 ans
et puis on peut se faire exempter quand
on a vraiment quelque chose sainte et
des problèmes de santé ou alors des
problèmes qui sont liés peut-être à des
problèmes personnels professionnels ou
non ça serait dramatique
alors il ya quatre sessions d'assises
parents combien de jurer par session
alors il ya en fait quatre ou cinq jurés
une session en première quand on était
en première instance il ya six jurés
avec les magistrats professionnels quand
on est en cause l'appel il ya neuf jurés
parmi ces jurys tous ne prennent pas
part au vote pourquoi alors parce que
vous avez des jurés supplémentaires qui
sont choisis qui habite forcément
tomber' qui viennent pour le cas où à
jour est titulaire au real est tombé
malade ne pourrait plus juger quelqu'un
assiste à tous les débats et puis il se
retire tout seul dans une salle au
moment des délibérés ils vont pas avec
les autres et il est vraiment besoin
d'un nouveau sur l'encadrement qui
accompagnent ces jurés alors les jurés
ont une formation de base au départ et
puis ensuite le magistrat professionnel
d'aiguines ils n'ont pas accès au
dossier pas plus qu' il n'y a que le
président les avocats et le parquet qui
ont accès au dossier une procédure orale
donc ils nécessitent une attention d'une
prise de notes et puis véritablement de
garder le côté humain des choses en
pesant le pour le contre et en évitant
que contient deuxième condition
merci m gezairy d'avoir répondu à toutes
nos questions